hey guys I am just McDonald here with
reviewer Edmund Tran and me this is our
video review for the division to tom
clancy's we should say and you gave it a
9 out of 10 I did which is a damn good
school a good school for a good game
that I had a lot of fun with a brave few
have sworn to protect us and save what
remains they unite us
remind us that we are one people they
are shielded and they're light but if
that light goes out
who can save us then so give us the a
major overview what is Tom Clancy's the
division term all right so Tom Clancy's
the division - is a third-person cover
shooter game there is also a loot
shooter what that's the term people use
in the vein of destiny or anthem whereby
it's a role-playing game in some aspects
where you are going through a campaign
getting better gear to better your own
character the way it handles its
progression it's an eight sort of
gameplay progression is very good
there's a lot of stuff for you to do and
it's always very clear about where your
next city of thick's might be coming
from there are definitely some downfalls
namely the lack of plot which is bizarre
and a bit of a disappointment but even
though that is a big sticking point for
me I felt like throughout the 60 hours I
played this game that was really only a
major concern of mine maybe the
beginning the first five yeah well let's
dig into it you mentioned the shooting
version of course is the bedrock of a
game like the division - what is it that
you really enjoy about the way that this
game implements combat so what the
religion - is a third-person tactical
cover shooter so you'll do a lot of
hiding behind waist-high walls a lot of
flanking and maneuvering around enemies
and a lot of popping up and taking your
potshots where you can find an opening
where the division two shooting really
comes to it into its own is in its enemy
variety so there are a lot of different
enemies and there's four factions in
Division two and they all have a variety
of different enemy archetypes within
those factions different ways they
behave and the way they move in their
way they try to sort of push you out of
your safe spot makes combat very
exciting yeah so for example there are a
lot of different melee enemies that like
to rush you and so they make you sort of
pick your priorities and make sure
you're not gonna get all right because
you know when you're out of covering the
division - you take a lot of damage yeah
the enemies are very proactive in
flanking and getting around the side and
behind you so you always into sort of
keep an eye on the battlefield there are
engineers we have sort of remote control
cars they can attack you from it
there are snipers which have to engage
at long range or sort of move up to them
yourself there are so many different
enemies they always like to be thinking
okay who's on the field right now how do
I deal with them what skills and
abilities do I have to deal with them
and do I want to engage this group at
long range do I want to outflank them
myself you always need to be thinking
about where your next move is or what
your next target is which makes the
cover shooting a lot more exciting than
other cover shooters where you kind of
just hunker down say one players wait
for your opportunity and take it in the
vision to your force to sort of make
those opportunities yourself or react
very quickly to what the enemies are
doing and they will like active very
quickly it's very easy to die in this
game so how did you feel about the
environments that those combat
engagements take place in whether the
open world or the mission main mission
environments and side mission
environments yeah the environments are
obviously a huge part of what makes the
combat great as well
division 2 takes place in a
post-apocalyptic Washington DC you know
when you first get into Washington DC
you can look pretty samey but the longer
you play the sort of the more you'd
learn to appreciate how the environments
have been designed for combat for
engagements especially in the main
missions and the side missions because
these take place in sort of significant
locations in Washington and they make
very good use of the spaces and set
pieces as well as interesting arenas to
sort of have a cover shooter style
skirmish so the one example I always
sort of hold up in high regard is that
there is a gunfight in planetarium which
is a round circular multi-tiered space
so typically in common shooters you come
into a hallway and you are looking down
the hallway and there is like one point
of engagement in the planetarium get in
there
it suddenly you're surrounded by all on
all sides by enemies you have no idea
where they're gonna flood in from and
along the way you can appreciate this
sort of the wonderful set dressing of it
all which is a working planetarium to
the exhibit will actually continue going
on as you're having this firefight so
seeing like space and they'll be stars
fly around and laser show some of the
stronghold which are kind of like longer
missions and if you play destiny that
kind of like strikes they stand out
quite a bit the reservoir island one in
particular is just sort of a mix of
indoor and outdoor and it just looks
really nice each battle always manages
to stay as exciting as your last battle
yeah well what I definitely want to move
on to from that is where that's
obviously this success at world building
and combat arena building that does seem
to have a collision in a point you
brought up in your review in progress
that we had go up which was one of the
your main complaints with the game which
is the story yeah look that's my biggest
complaint about the game is the
divisions sort of lack of story
obviously there was a lot of incidental
narrative there's a lot of well building
in the game there is a general narrative
set up that yes you are there's been a
virus outbreak society has crumbled the
division are a government sleeper unit
that has activated in order to restore
the way we were restore the government
and so on and so forth and the fact that
a bunch of armed factions have
splintered off and become gangs beyond
that set up there is not a lot the
division gives you I don't want to say
it's bad because it's not enough of it
there to be really bad that's just not
there you should go check in with her if
anyone knows how to get these systems
back online it's her there are no strong
plot threads to grasp at as you followed
through the main story missions there
are hints of things like oh the leader
of this settlement her daughter's been
kidnapped it's like okay I'm gonna go
save a daughter and then you do a
mission meet you shoot a bunch of dudes
you reach the door and the in the room
at the end of the mission and that's
kind of it you don't really hear from
her or her daughter again you just on to
the next thing
and I think that's also hindered a bit
by the fact that this is in an
open-world game and it lets you do sort
of whatever you want you can just go off
and do a million other things and come
back to another mission by which time
you you know you just have no idea
what's going on anymore you know not
that there was anything going on to
begin with and I feel like given this
setting of the division 2 you know
there's a whole lot of talk about the
politics of the division 2 which they've
said is a political but it's very hard
to be a political when you're setting a
game set in Washington DC about the
government and society and factions and
how they sort of
come into conflict with each other so it
feels like a big kind of wasted
opportunity I was really intrigued in
the first division to sort of find out
the mystery behind the virus and how it
came to be who was behind it but in this
one there's just there was just none of
that any angle would have been
interesting then no angle in terms of
making us care about the people in this
game and what's happening to them I
think something for me that really
emphasizes the point you just made is
another thing you mentioned in your
review in progress which which also
backs the point that it can have a story
that's disappointing and still be a game
this gray is in the mint when you
mentioned at the very final mission of
the game the very final boss you cannot
for the life of you remember who that
boss's name was and neither can i but it
definitely at least for me didn't
detract from the the joy I felt having
gone through that and I feel like when I
think about I remember the places as you
said the places you are in the tactics
that you used and also the people you
played with if not the story and the
reason you were doing it yeah hi I'm
Emma
I've been recruited to help out at your
base of operations with recalibrating
and fine-tuning equipment glad to be
working with you but there's motivation
in sort of the settlement aspect of the
game in your journey to sort of liberate
Washington DC from all the other
factions who aren't you yeah you come
across these civilian settlements and
they are downtrodden and they have I
just scratch scraping by and a lot of
what you do in the game is to their
benefit so you are gathering resources
and collectibles in the world to bring
back to them to build up amenities and
sort of resources to help them be self
sustainable but the way you complete
those and return back to the settlements
and see how those things you've been
doing out in the world have contributed
to that someone becoming a more lively
more vibrant more positive place full of
more people and life that's rewarding in
itself yeah because it's a very visible
indicator of progress contributing to
those settlements just is is one of the
biggest motivators that keeps you going
especially in the early game due to the
lack of plot many action well I'm glad
you brought up progression because I'd
also like to talk about
character predict progression
particularly with regard to the apogee
elements of this game have a very good
loop that keeps you excited to get the
next thing the way they do that is by
loop obviously you pick up new Ghia you
equip your division agent with pieces of
armor as well as weaponry and you can
mod all that stuff later on down the
line and the way that becomes compelling
in its own right is through a bunch of
things one they give you a lot of it
there is a lot of loot in this game you
always know that every activity you do
will give you at least one specific kind
of gear you know that there are a lot of
different containers in the world that
you can get loot from if you go out of
your way to look for them and all of
that is valuable because you can break
all that down and take it back to base
and craft it or buy it
there's always an avenue to get loot
that makes you better at what you do I
mean that goes the same for your own
experience as well because every
activity you do get to your experience
points um in the campaign you level from
0 to 30 30s the cap obviously have to do
the main missions to measure to complete
the story that there are a wealth of
activities in the open world like random
events in the world like executions or
like supply convoys on that you can
hijack they get experience you can do
side missions you can just run around
the world and kill enemies for
experience whatever you do in this game
you will get rewarded and that feels
good as a loot shooter so let's talk
about endgame I this was one of the
major complaints for the division one
was not having a substantial enough
endgame and there's been some talk that
this has been really addressed this time
around what is the framework of endgame
how does it work and what is that a
doing at this time around right so once
you push the campaign you hit level 30
which are required to do they finish the
campaign you at the endgame where your
stature in the world is measured by the
quality of your gear so you have a gear
score and the sort of soft cap to that
at Lord is 450 once you finish the
campaign the whole world just sort of
flips itself on its head right so what
happens is everything you've sort of
worked to uncover and retake throughout
the campaign get retaken by a new enemy
faction called the black tusk and they
invade a bunch of
their main story locations as was the
strongholds and so it's your job in
endgame to retake those locations again
but this time from a different faction
that behaves in a much more aggressive
much more organized manner so the
enemies themselves are tougher which
keeps the combat challenging throughout
the curve of combat difficulty just
keeps going and still stays tense but to
help you with that you also get to pick
from one of three specializations which
is sort of their class system and you
want to get a new skill tree to sort of
put points into so that means even after
you've finished loving up to level 30
and sort of unlocked all your special
skills and perks and stuff like that
you have another trader fill out which
gives you additional perks and benefits
to help combat the tower enemies and as
you slowly finish these missions the
world will go up by tiers
there's world tiers want to fall
currently with multi 5 coming and that
means that the enemies and the the
general sort of activities in the open
world outside of the missions gets like
tougher to sort of match your
proficiency in your capability in your
ability to deal damage so given that the
new world tiers are still using the same
map these invaded missions are still
using the same mission locations and
things like that what keeps it engaging
for you having already done it well the
black tasks adds a lot to it it's the
variety of their units that keeps things
interesting keeps you on your toes black
tusk like I said we're more organized
they're way more aggressive they have
unique units like Boston Dynamics elf
robot dog that Snipes it's their
behavior that keeps you thinking in new
ways it keeps you thinking about okay
maybe I need to equip this skill for
these guys instead of that other one
when I was playing through the division
I didn't have a reason to replay a story
mission after I played the first time
and it was kind of nice to revisit the
Natural History Museum to revisit
Planetarium to revisit these sports
arenas and so some of the really nice
set pieces that I've only seen once
before I definitely found myself doing
the same sort of missions 5 or 6 times
but that's because I was using one of
the new multiplayer options which is
call for backup and onto the call yeah I
would love to hear your thoughts on how
you
you found the new multiple options and
how the game deals with multiplayer in
general i think the most play it was
done really well really seamlessly so i
played most of the division to solo I
think the vision to is it very shelled
solo a ball game in general maybe all
the way up until you hit the the end of
the end of the end game stuff which is
really really tough playing solo makes
you sort of think way more tactically
about your positions and makes you
consider your options and far more
carefully than if you were in a group
yeah that said it's really fun to play
the division 2 multiplayer you're able
to just match make a very specific
mission and just put the call out to
everyone would be like hey you want to
help me with this mission and typically
in my experience you would find people
to fill out a full person squad very
easily and the best thing about that is
that it's not restricted to the
beginning of a mission so there are a
few instances where I was going through
a stronghold or a main mission and solo
and I would come up against the boss
which I was having trouble with and it's
like I'm gonna call for backup and you
know throwing off someone would jump
into my game
mid boss fight and just help me out with
it you can match make for sort of
open-world activities in free roam and
bounties and stuff like that but I found
that I was less successful at matching
with other people in those kind of
situations yeah probably because
everyone was doing the campaign you
yourself can be wandering the world and
get a call for backup of a nearby agent
and choose to help I suggest you do well
that kind of feeds into a question we
got from Mark on Twitter you say you
answer some segments of this question
but he wanted to know if the solo
experience has changed much from the
division one and not being a multiplayer
fan how much of the game can be
completed solo so you did mention before
there are some bits which are probably
not impossible but very difficult solo
what would you say those are
specifically um I would say the extreme
if you'll if you're looking to just go
through the story sort of difficulty
missions I think no problem you know I'm
at the endgame now at the at the gear
score cap and I'm doing sort of like
level 3 challenging control points which
are cool activities I can do those solo
like it's
problem if I just you know play
conservatively and play smartly once you
get to conflict level four for those
specific areas or if you want to start
diving into hard and challenging
versions of missions that's when you
kind of need to think about more having
some backup the other exception is
perhaps the dark zone which is the
divisions pvp ve areas so there are
three distinct areas in the map which
are cordoned off for good rewards but
also tough enemies and the ability to
fight other players so in these areas
everything is normalized
which means all your gear stats sort of
don't matter and it's just an even
playing ground yeah so now in the
Division two there is plenty of loot
that you can pick up from enemies from
killing enemies or from looting
containers that you can just use you use
instantly there is still contaminated
loot that you need to extract and that
aspect of it still exists but the stuff
you get from the dark zone normally is
still good and it still feels good to
come out of the dark zone with like a
whole backpack full of new stuff well
there was another comment that came in
around the time that your review in
progress was posted from p1p3 dream who
said if you enjoyed the first game
you're going to really like this game if
you didn't this isn't going to win you
over
that's a comment I'd be interested to
hear your input on I mean I played and
enjoyed the division once I currently
speak with authority to someone who
hasn't the division one I mean I can say
that the division two does falter in
that it doesn't have a sort of plot to
sort of latch on to if you found the
division one sort of squishiness and
enemies to sort of be a big factor in so
if you're just like event it might
interest you to know that the topper
enemies have visible armor that you have
to sort of work at breaking away before
you can do actual damage to them and
that system feels good you know I think
that's that's fair to say if you don't
like loot readers who don't like the
setting of the division in general yeah
you're probably not gonna like the
division - so what's your ultimate
takeaway for the division - and for
people who may be interested in picking
it up if they haven't already
look my ultimate takeaway is if you like
loot shooter games then the division -
like
is a very good one the world in the
environments and the setups and the
combat in the sense of progression and
the the motivation you have to do all
that stuff is really on point it's very
sharp the lack of a plot is a really
disappointing overlook that you know in
my overall experience that those
concerns only took up about the first
sort of five to ten hours of everything
and the rest of it was just once that
all fell by the wayside I was just
having a great time shooting exploring
environments getting better gear all the
way up until endgame and yet I want to
go out and play the division to you
again right now okay yeah no it's it's
it's fantastic
alright well there you guys have it if
you are after the written version about
for review you can find it on GameSpot
right now and there's plenty more
features to tuck into and gameplay to
watch if you want to do so we'll see you
again soon
you